the multi-annual financial framework the
first element on this item is the
organization of our work it will be
further developed with a view to
reaching an agreement by the end of 2012
the update is consisting of two parts
first one much more interesting is about
figures and second is minor amendments
to the text of multi-annual framework
regulation as for the reasons for the
figures update Vera free of them four of
them firstly Croatia second is update of
the cohesion envelopes third is update
of payment ceilings and the fourth and
final is how to express the volumes in
terms of percentage of gnite where
result mainly open cohesion envelopes is
minus point five point five billion for
decrease by 5.5 billion for thought for
27 I would like to to present very
shortly and on behalf of the 15 member
states friends of cohesion a few
messages which which we believe are
vital at this stage of of the process
the result of the update is actually no
more money for cohesion countries in you
27 but less money for cohesion countries
in you 27 and we we have to we have to
note that this is not consistent with
the message of the of the European
Council we should not forget that the
starting point is a nominal freeze in
cohesion policy after the update we come
to the conclusion that we have reached
the limits of further reductions in
cohesion policy vengeance budget and
that's the message which which I should
jump the size extremely strong extremely
strongly we have reached the limits of
further cuts in cohesion policy thank
you Hungary is by far
in the most disadvantaged situation of
the deserved it or together we would
face are close to thirty percent
reduction in our cohesion allocations
and it is politically unacceptable for a
member states whose level of development
is forecast to remain well below 75
percent of the EU average we have many
friends and perhaps for this reason
appropriate Christo we don't agree non
siamo de corredor with the current
proposal for technical update because
everything at the problem problem man so
it's not so much financial that call mr.
political that is the most important
problem of the problem of clearance we
don't think that this is consistent with
the general objectives of growth and
question of employment ticularly in
lemoore disadvantaged regions of our
union league one of our main concerns
from Germany is this principle better
spending better sadly we've got to look
at improving the quality expenditure
without bringing involving members in
micromanagement we need clear rules to
decide now we can spend the money for
intelligent growth that is the key point
intelligent the priority for us is that
there should be a firm ceiling on the
overall size of the budget framework the
Commission's original proposal of jun
2011 is at least 100 billion euros too
big in terms of payments I do think it's
remarkable now the answer to weakening
growth outlook in a debt crisis would be
an increased budgets and not reduced
budgets together with many colleagues
around this table I have repeatedly
during the meetings who've had during
the spring stress the need for real
freeze of payment in the next
bodied period and fossil member state
contribution future EU budget should
emphasize investments into policy
stimulating you competitiveness economic
growth and job creation in cohesion the
key policy to reach this the real
challenges of future EU budget is to
spend our resources in a better way the
principle of better spending means
simple implementation rules and our
model relation modernization or
exploited shop policies reiterate simply
three principles that continue to be of
importance to us that is the top down
approach in order to come to a realistic
an adequate spending level better
spending growth and jobs must come
through increased in competitiveness in
the union we must recognize that the
budget will have to have a level that is
commensurate with the political and
economic realities these days in our
member states is a real threat it's not
imaginary and it goes beyond the overall
expenditure of the budget of the
European Union and at this moment in
time this threat if it were to
materialize would be disastrous not only
for the Friends of cohesion group but
for the EU in general for the mff we
think it is a solid program you can
count on our cooperation and FA valla
support you in every way to have an
agreement on a disability and over the
year however we think this goes beyond
in the correction for the entrance of a
Croatia and beyond purely and technical
considerations we think this goes in the
wrong direction and it then does not
take account of the message of a
limiting
the mff to approximately one percent of
the EU gee and I thought rimsky contrada
know if we want to be careful we should
not adjust to the detriment of the least
favored areas cohesion policy has an
important role to play a fundamental
role to play in growth and jobs this has
been recognized by the last European
Council I would just like to recall that
Denmark has one and only one decisive
priority in these negotiations and that
is that we need a net correction on the
revenue side of 150 million euro
annually from 2014 to solve our problem
of an excessive budgetary contribution
on updated Commission proposal it's
clear that the Commission's updated
proposal is of technical niche hence
it's only natural that it doesn't
address any of our three main problems
cohesion capping safety direct payments
and the commissioning of inulin a
nuclear power plant Austria is in favor
of cutting the overall volume of the mff
by at least one hundred thousand million
euros for my country the main issue is
how the mff can contribute to growth
more precisely how the mff can
contribute to smart sustainable growth
it's no surprise that we were not fully
satisfied with the outcome of the
results of the update which also sends a
quite different signal comparing to June
Council conclusions Romania considers
that the proposal concerning the
substantial reduction of the level of a
location all the proposals are not
sustainable importance of not having
policies clashing with each other or
fully aware of the important role played
by the cohesion
policy and what it does for growth just
like common agricultural policy we are
concerned about the decrease in the
cohesion policy envelope we believe that
the budget for the less developed
regions should not be affected by any
possible cuts in order not to slow down
the convergence process what our police
corps colleague said at the beginning of
the debate reflects to a great extent
our thinking for the cohesion policy as
being a growth friendly polishing and we
welcome the work done by Commission in
updating the proposal for next time ffs
meanwhile stressing that the sufficient
financing has to be ensured for
investment through the heating policy
despite the fact that the Asian policy
amount is decreasing with this update we
consider it to be purely technical
exercise and we shouldn't allow this
technical exercise to overshadows a
debate on the political girls and
contact we would just like to stress
once again the importance of cohesion
policy in our overall efforts to
increase growth jobs and pull through
these difficult times and if we think
we're going to be able to considerably
reduce the Commission's proposals
independently of any debate on the
federal responsibility of the most days
solidarity between them more federal
Europe and a growth plan seems to me
absurd the next step will be as I was
alluding to a substantial discussion at
our informal meeting in Nicosia on 30th
of August